[Music]
welcome back to science clique today
entropy and the arrow of time
consider the following two images
the first represents a precise structure
an apple
the second has no structure
it is homogeneous
now imagine that we generate a third
image by randomly choosing the color of
each pixel
once the image is generated we can pair
it with the previous two
which of these two images does the new
image resemble the most
visually the random image looks more
like image number two homogeneous
both have no particular structure
unlike the apple
if we keep generating new random images
most of them will resemble image number
two
the probability of randomly creating the
image of an apple is very low
in general we will rather get a
disordered image without structure
it is this property of looking like
something random that we call entropy
here image number two has more entropy
because it more often looks like a
random image
[Music]
in our universe entropy is defined in
the same way the universe is made up of
atoms which can arrange themselves in
many ways and some of these arrangements
seem homogeneous like a gas whilst
others have structures like an ice cube
or an apple
if we randomly generate a new
arrangement by choosing the position and
speed of each atom
we are more likely to create a
homogeneous arrangement which will look
like a gas rather than an apple or an
ice cube
therefore we say that a gas has more
entropy because it looks more like a
random distribution
more specifically the entropy of an
object is a number which counts among
all possible arrangements those which
resemble our object
the idea is that at our scale the lack
of precision of our measurements and the
very large number of atoms prevent us
from seeing the differences between
these arrangements
although they are technically different
at our scale they all seem identical
let's take a look at these two images
when we look at them very closely we can
distinguish the color of each pixel and
it is therefore possible to
differentiate one from the other
but if we look from further away the
precise details of each image are no
longer visible and the two images now
look identical
[Music]
going back to physics the entropy of an
ice cube is thus lower than that of a
gas because there are many more
configurations that look like the gas
rather than the ice cube
in a way entropy measures the degree of
freedom that atoms have it tells us
whether our object requires a precise
configuration or whether it can
fluctuate through many arrangements
while keeping the same appearance
[Music]
in a low entropy system the water
molecules do not have much freedom they
only have access to very few precise
configurations and their agitation is
very weak which explains why the ice
cube is cold
conversely in a high entropy system such
as vapor the molecules are much freer
and can fluctuate through many different
arrangements
they are very agitated
hence the high temperature
intuitively the notion of entropy
therefore allows us to characterize the
state of matter solid liquid or gas
when we boil water for example the
energy we provide it with heat allows us
to increase its entropy that is to say
to free the molecules which compose it
to give them a more random disordered
behavior and thus transition to a phase
of higher entropy vapor
the notion of entropy is very useful in
physics and chemistry in particular for
characterizing states of matter
but as we have seen with the example of
images the notion is much more
fundamental and can extend to a
multitude of other fields
[Music]
in mathematics shannon's entropy
measures the amount of information
contained in an object such as text
a repeating text contains little
information because it suffices to
identify the repeating formula to fully
describe it
a more random less structured text
contains a lot of information because
the only possible way to describe it is
to indicate each character one by one
[Music]
in computer science algorithmic entropy
is quite similar and measures the
complexity for a computer to generate a
specific object
the more information the object contains
the less it is possible to compress the
code that describes it
the idea of entropy is even used in the
study of biodiversity because it allows
us to quantify the range of variations
within a set of elements
it is also useful in the study of
chaotic systems to characterize their
unpredictable random behavior
such as the fact that in the long term a
double pendulum can be affected by very
small disturbance
[Music]
finally the study of black holes allow
us to assign these entities an entropy
which measures the amount of information
they have swallowed
the entropy of a black hole is
distributed over its surface and the
more information it captures by
absorbing new objects the larger the
black hole becomes
[Music]
finally entropy plays a crucial role in
our understanding of time
and more particularly the direction in
which transformations happen
[Music]
to understand imagine the following two
configurations
on the one hand a balloon is open inside
a box and the balloon contains a gas
with high pressure
on the other hand we imagine the same
balloon open but this time the gas is
evenly distributed inside the box
[Music]
assuming that the box evolves
spontaneously can we guess the
chronological order in which these two
situations occur
was the gas first compressed in the
balloon and then escaped over time
or was it the other way around was the
gas initially homogeneous and then
compressed into the balloon
intuitively our daily experience tells
us that the gas has escaped from the
balloon that it would tend to diffuse
rather than spontaneously return inside
in general we have the intuition that
physical systems tend to homogenize over
time
that tensions like the pressure in the
balloon tend to relax
if we put a hot object in contact with a
cold object we expect for example that
their temperatures would gradually
equalize
yet on a microscopic scale the two
states do not seem to have a fundamental
difference
it is difficult to understand why the
phenomenon would necessarily occur in
one direction rather than the other
it is at this point that the notion of
entropy is crucial
we saw previously that the entropy of an
object is greater when the object seems
homogeneous
the second state therefore has greater
entropy than the first and it is
precisely for this reason that the
process occurs in this direction rather
than in the other
when we let a system evolve
spontaneously its entropy tends to
increase
making the system more and more
homogeneous
over time the entropy of an isolated
system always tends to grow
but behind this very powerful principle
actually hides a simple logical
explanation
to understand it let's go back to our
analogy from the beginning
a structured image that represents an
apple
[Music]
at every instant we imagine making the
color of each pixel of the image
fluctuate slightly and we observe its
evolution over time
at the microscopic scale the image
fluctuates and gradually drifts away
from its initial configuration
as time passes it will go through
multiple different arrangements passing
randomly from one to the other
but at our scale the image of the apple
seems to gradually fade it becomes more
and more homogeneous until perfectly
resembling the grey image we had seen at
the beginning
by fluctuating at random the image
itself has become more and more random
and as we saw at the beginning of the
video an image whose pixels are random
has a very high probability of being
homogeneous
in our universe atoms are agitated and
their microscopic distribution
constantly fluctuates passing
spontaneously from one configuration to
another
if we wait long enough the structure of
the universe tends to be more and more
random on a microscopic scale
and of random structure most often tends
to be homogeneous
[Music]
as time goes by the structures in our
universe have the tendency to blur while
its total entropy continues to increase
the entropy of the universe measures the
progression of its homogenization
over time
[Music]
to conclude entropy is a fascinating
concept
although very concrete allowing us to
characterize the state of mata and their
transformations it ultimately boils down
to very simple ideas
in particular entropy explains the arrow
of time the direction in which the
universe evolves through simple
probabilistic logic
atoms can be arranged in many different
ways
but from our point of view some of these
configurations look the same and in
particular those which are the most
homogeneous
as there are more of them by fluctuating
little by little the universe naturally
tends to adopt them in the long term
today the question arises as to whether
the universe will end up being
completely homogeneous
one could imagine that by constantly
increasing its entropy would eventually
reach a maximum that the universe would
reach a point of equilibrium and that
the arrow of time would disappear
only microscopic fluctuations would
remain
however the universe is expanding and
the phenomena of general relativity
linked to its structural geometry can
perhaps prevent it from this scenario of
heat death
[Music]
you